fractured light cascading from the
ceiling like the light through palm
trees in the desert a design project
from Abu Dhabi now on display at the
architecture biennale in Venice it's one
of the most important architecture shows
in the world revered and inspiring but
it's also about solutions festival
curator Alejandro Aravena is searching
for answers to the problems of our time
architecture is about giving form to the
places where people live it's not more
complicated than that but it's also not
easier than that one question here is
how to accommodate the world's growing
population one idea efficient
construction like the fun fill home by
Indian architect anupama kundu she's
experimented with different materials to
build affordable homes for people in
tropical regions with her concept she
hopes to bring safer housing to the poor
we have environmental crisis social
crisis and ecological economic crisis
together so the the one way to address
all of that is we cannot afford to build
the way we used to we have to build with
significantly less 64 countries are
exhibiting their ideas for socially
conscious architecture in the US
pavilion the focus is on the future of
cities using Detroit America's poorest
major city as its model architects
display their vision for reviving
rundown neighborhoods what we wanted was
to post alternatives to the projects
that are happening in Detroit today
which tend to be driven by economic
interests and instead create a context
for conversations in Detroit or what the
possibilities for the future might be
the German pavilion takes a look at the
current migration crisis the focus here
is on making Germany home a welcoming
place for new arrivals the exhibition
showcases modern highly social refugee
centers with the idea of German cities
as rival points doesn't advantage we're
really convinced by the idea of the
arrival city as a place to welcome
newcomers and give them opportunities
this can be done by simply offering
better accessibility and opportunities
it's all going this kite
rubbish chitin earth net new
perspectives on ways to live together on
display at the architecture biennale in
Venice until November